el conjunto de precios de computadoras
portátiles tiene una distribución normal
con una media de 750 pesos y una
desviación estándar de 60 pesos cuál es
la proporción de los precios que se
encuentran entre los 624 y los 768 pesos
primero veamos qué es lo que nos piden
tenemos una distribución normal para los
precios que se ve más o menos así
tenemos la media justo en el centro que
es 750 pesos también nos dicen que
tenemos una desviación estándar de 60
pesos una desviación estándar está por
aquí y es 750 más 60 que son 810 pesos y
una desviación estándar por debajo de la
media está por acá y es 750 menos 60 que
nos da 690 pesos después nos preguntan
cuál es la proporción de los precios que
se encuentran entre los 624 y 768 pesos
el límite inferior está más abajo que
una desviación estándar 624 pesos 768
pesos estarán más o menos por aquí
y nos preguntan cuál es la proporción
que se encuentra entre estos dos valores
nos interesa el área bajo esta
distribución entre estos dos valores la
forma como vamos a abordar esto es
encontrar el puntaje z
para 768 que será positivo porque está
por encima de la media y usaremos una
tabla zeta para encontrar la proporción
que se encuentra por debajo de 768 vamos
a encontrar toda esta área incluyendo lo
que está por debajo de 624 después
encontraremos el puntaje z para 624 que
será negativo porque está por debajo de
la media y de nuevo usaremos la tabla
zeta para encontrar la proporción por
debajo de 624 para que al final podamos
restar esta área de aquí a esta otra
área de la proporción menor a 768 y así
encontrar el área entre ambas vamos a
hacer lo encontremos primero el puntaje
z de 768 y luego encontraremos el
puntaje de 624 el puntaje z de 768 es
igual a 768
- 750 / la desviación estándar que es 60
esto es 18 entre 60 que podemos
simplificar a 6 entre 20 y que es igual
a 0.30
este es el puntaje z para el límite
superior veamos cuál es la proporción
menor a esto y para eso usamos la tabla
zeta
buscamos 0.30 la primera columna tiene
el puntaje z hasta las décimas ya lo
hemos visto en vídeos anteriores y para
encontrar las centésimas vemos estos
valores de aquí arriba
buscamos 0.30 este es el renglón y esta
es la columna por lo que la proporción
es 0.6 1.179 lo escribimos ahora hagamos
lo mismo pero para la proporción por
debajo de 624 el puntaje z de 624 es 624
menos la media que es 750 todo esto
entre 60 sacamos la calculadora y
ponemos 624 menos 750
es menos 126 que dividimos entre 60 y
nos da menos 2.1 el límite inferior está
2.1 desviaciones estándar por debajo de
la media o podemos decir que tiene un
puntaje z de menos 2.1 lo escribimos
para encontrar la proporción por debajo
de este valor vemos de nuevo la tabla
zeta este puntaje es negativo ya que son
desviaciones estándar por debajo de la
media hacemos lo mismo aquí está el
puntaje hasta las décimas y por acá
están las centésimas
buscamos menos 2.1 o también podemos
decir que es menos 2.10 para ser más
precisos lo buscamos 2.1 está aquí y no
tenemos centésimas por lo que nos
interesa esta columna así que la
proporción que es menor a 624 es cero
punto 0 179 lo escribimos si queremos
encontrar la proporción que se encuentra
entre estos dos valores restamos esta
área
de 624 del área más grande que es de 768
0.6 mil 179 menos 0 puntos 0 179 nos va
a dar 0.6 si queremos que nuestra
respuesta tenga cuatro cifras decimales
escribimos 0.6 mil otra forma de pensar
en esto es que exactamente el 60 por
ciento se encuentra entre 624 y 768